This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On The Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。在Look Back at it播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个巨大的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
您收听的是由您最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·加姆斯主持的《狠狠吸取教训》。这个空间专注于黑人的经历，进行在任何地方都真正不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。请在AHA广播应用程序、Apple Podcast或您获取播客的任何地方收听并狠狠吸取教训。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
艾伦女士，你对这个特定的测试做了两次手脚，对吧？我动过一次测试的手脚。这需要一支互联网侦探大军来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《被困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《被困之爱》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性、健康和抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》？也就是在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方搜索TWA%。
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of your 20s. the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology of our 20s. Today, we're going to look into, we're going to explore. I think we're going to be able to explore. I think we're one of the most important concepts when it comes to building healthy, realistic relationships
大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一档我们探讨你二十岁时的一些生活。这是一档我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们的心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能来到这里收听另一期节目，我们一起剖析二十岁的心理学。今天，我们要深入探讨，我们要探索。我想我们将能够探索。我认为我们即将探讨的是在建立健康、现实的恋爱关系时最核心的概念之一
in our 20s, whether that's when we are dating, when we are building new friendships, or even as we begin to see our parents as real people and kind of navigating that new relationship. What we're talking about is fantasy bonding. Fantasy bonding is one of those concepts taken from psychology that I've definitely seen gaining a lot of popularity and colloquial usage in online spaces. And it often is used to kind of refer to the bonds we create with potential partners or love interests in a very kind of like misconstrued sense. Often we think that fantasy bonding is a, you know, just this idea of like having a fantasy about someone and therefore bonding with them over it, which is in some ways true.
在我们二十岁的时候，无论那是在我们约会时，在我们建立新的友谊时，甚至在我们开始将父母视为真正的人并开始摸索那种新关系时。我们要谈论的是幻想粘合（fantasy bonding）。幻想粘合是心理学中借用的概念之一，我绝对看到它在网络空间中越来越受欢迎并在日常口语中被广泛使用。而且它经常被用来指代我们在一种非常扭曲的意义上与潜在伴侣或心仪对象建立的联系。通常我们认为幻想粘合是，你知道的，仅仅是关于对某人产生幻想并因此与他们建立联系的想法，这在某种程度上是真的。
But I think it ignores a lot of the really important psychological origins. that are not understood, and that is such a shame, because once we really understand the nature of fantasy bonding, I think so much about our lives begins to make so much more sense. We can gain a whole new understanding of how we approach relationships, why that is, and we begin to be able to identify the kind of invisible string or pattern that ties a lot of our relationships together. And that is that a lot of the time we are a lot more attached to our idea of someone or their potential than the reality of who they actually are. Our relationships become defined a lot more by our perceptions, by wishful thinking, sometimes even willful ignorance, than who this person
但我认为它忽略了许多真正重要的心理根源，而这些根源并没有被理解，这真是一个遗憾，因为一旦我们真正理解了幻想粘合的本质，我认为我们生活中的很多事情就会开始变得更有意义。我们可以对我们如何对待关系获得全新的理解，为什么会这样，并且我们开始能够识别出将我们的许多关系联系在一起的那种无形的线索或模式。那就是很多时候，我们对某人的想法或潜力的依附，要远远多于他们实际是谁的现实。我们的定义更多是由我们的感知、厢愿情愿、有时甚至是明知故犯的无知所决定，而不是这个人
and what this relationship truly could be. So let's talk about it. First off, I really want to start by giving you a bit of history behind where this term originated, because although it's usually used to refer to dating and instances of dating, it starts a lot earlier than that. So fantasy bonding was a term created by Dr. Robert Firestone in his book, literally titled The Fantasy Bomb. And it was published quite a while ago, almost 40 years ago in 1985. And he used it to describe primarily the connection we typically form with our parents and how we all have essentially this emotional hunger and need to see our parents or our caregivers as utterly perfect and endlessly able to provide us with all of our needs, all of the love, comfort, resources that we need, but also the security
以及这段关系真正可能成为什么样。所以我们来聊聊这个。首先，我真的想从这个术语起源的历史背景开始讲起，因为尽管它通常被用来指代约会和约会中的情况，但它的起点要比那早得多。所以幻想粘合是罗伯特·费尔斯通博士在他的书中创造的一个术语，该书字面上的标题就是《幻想粘合》。它发表于相当长的一段时间以前，几乎是40年前的1985年。他用它来主要描述我们通常与父母形成的联系，以及我们所有人本质上都有这种情感上的饥渴和需求，希望将我们的父母或照顾者视为绝对完美、能够无休止地满足我们所有需求的至高存在，提供给我们所有的爱、安慰、资源，但同时也是安全感
that we crave, even when sometimes they aren't able to do that. So therefore, based on this bond, And based on this fantasy that we have of our parents, we end up idealizing them in order to trust them through everything. So essentially, a fantasy bond in this form is what we would call a primitive defense mechanism. And we, like I said, develop it in early childhood as a way of maintaining an illusion of safety and security that is tied to our parents, even when we are experiencing a lot of hurt. or terror. It lets us see our parents as our savior in an attempt to kind of cope with emotional pain. When we are as children really terrified or scared or hurt, we have this kind of vision of our parents as being able to fix that for us. We have this version of our parents in our imagination who are, and we see them as these all-powerful, all-healing kind of God-like people and a lot of our relationship with them
我们渴望的那种安全感，即使有时他们根本无法做到这一点。因此，基于这种纽带，并且基于我们对父母的这种幻想，我们最终会理想化他们，以便在经历一切时信任他们。所以本质上，这种形式的幻想粘合就是我们所说的原始防御机制。正如我所说，我们在幼儿时期发展它，作为一种维持与父母绑定的安全和保障错觉的方式，即使我们在经历很多伤害或恐怖时也是如此。它让我们把父母视为我们的救世主，以此来应付情感上的痛苦。当我们作为孩子感到真正的惊恐、害怕或受伤时，我们在想象中对父母有一种愿景，即他们能够为我们解决这个问题。我们在想象中拥有这样版本的父母，我们把他们看作是这种全能的、全能治愈的、如神一般的人物，我们与他们的很多关系
in the early years of our lives, incorporates that fantasy bond. So if you think about it, if we were from a very young age, to see our parents the way that we see them now in our 20s as kind of real humans, as flawed people as everyone is, if we were to see them that way as children, that would have made us feel a lot less safe about the world, especially at times when we were really vulnerable. So it's only as we get older that we really begin, to realize that our parents can't stop us from feeling pain. They can't cure all our illnesses.
在我们生命早期融入了那种幻想粘合。所以如果你仔细想想，如果我们从很小的时候起，就像我们现在二十岁时看待他们那样看待我们的父母，把他们当作真正的人、像所有人一样有缺陷的人来对待，如果我们作为孩子那样看待他们，那会让我们对世界的安全感大打折扣，尤其是在我们非常脆弱的时候。所以只有当我们长大后，我们才真正开始意识到，我们的父母无法阻止我们感受到痛苦。他们无法治愈我们所有的疾病。
They can't stop terrible things from happening in that. In fact, they may, at times, be just as scared as us. So this fantasy bond serves a purpose in our early childhood. It also can sometimes protect us from remembering the times that our parents weren't the best parents, the times that they screwed up or they hurt us or they did the wrong thing. Because as children, we really have no one else to rely on but these caregivers. And yet we are so fragile. And so if there was to be something that would cause us to not see our parents as being able to help us and being these very powerful creatures, we really wouldn't have any sense of security in the world. Most people grow out of the fantasy bond that they have with their parents. It becomes more realistic. For those
他们无法阻止可怕的事情发生。事实上，他们有时可能和我们一样害怕。因此，这种幻想粘合在我们的幼儿期起到了作用。它有时也能保护我们免于记起父母并不是最好的父母的时刻，记起他们搞砸了、伤害了我们或做错了事的时刻。因为作为孩子，除了这些照顾者，我们真的无人可依。然而我们又是如此脆弱。因此，如果有什么事情导致我们不再把父母视为能够帮助我们、拥有强大力量的人，我们在世界上将完全失去安全感。大多数人最终会走出与父母的幻想粘合。它变得更加现实。对于那些
that don't, we have people who will continue to idealize their parents and family, seeing it through rose-colored lenses. Maybe you have encountered people who are like, oh, you know, there was always something wrong with me as a kid. My parents were great. Like, I was a bad kid. They did whatever they could. They're like my hero. They're amazing. I think that some of those, like, appraisals are good things to have, like respecting your parents, loving your parents, appreciating them. Totally normal. And sometimes there is nothing wrong with. without childhoods, that would cause us to not believe that. But I think this more refers to people who have had this fantasy bond to the point, this fantasy bond to the point where it's kind of created
没有走出的人，我们会看到有人继续理想化他们的父母和家庭，戴着玫瑰色的眼镜来看待它。也许你遇到过这样的人：“哦，你知道，我小时候总是有问题。我父母太棒了。我是个坏孩子。他们做了他们能做的一切。他们就像我的英雄。他们太棒了。”我认为其中一些评估是好事，比如尊重父母、爱父母、欣赏他们。完全正常。有时童年并没有什么不对的地方，不至于让我们不相信这一点。但我认为这更多指的是那些已经将幻想粘合发展到这种程度的人，这种幻想粘合已经
an unbalanced relationship. For example, maybe they bring a new family member in. They start dating someone. They've talked about how their family is like amazing that parents could do anything. And then like the new girlfriend, the new boyfriend, the new partner comes in and it's like, whoa, like there's a lot going on here. This, my partner. is definitely like has this idea of their parents that is not real. The other thing that a fantasy bond does is that once we have kind of learnt that we can dissociate from the reality of who someone is and create a version of them that is useful for us, we can begin to replicate that bond in our adult relationships primarily in our romantic lives.
造成了一种不平衡的关系。例如，也许他们引入了一个新的家庭成员。他们开始跟某人约会。他们一直在说他们的家庭多么了不起，父母无所不能。然后，新的女朋友、新的男朋友、新的伴侣进来了，情况就像是：“哇，这里有很多事情正在发生。我的伴侣绝对对他们的父母有一种不真实的看法。”幻想粘合的另一个作用是，一旦我们某种程度上学会了我们可以从一个人的真实面目中解离出来，并创造出一个对我们有用的他们的版本，我们就可以开始在我们的成年关系中复制这种纽带，主要是在我们的浪漫生活中。
And that is what I really want to talk about today. This is when we get the fantasy bond that we most often talk about when it comes to. to dating. A fantasy bond situation can be something that any of us finds ourselves in because it is basically like relying on a very human trait, which is our imagination. And what it does is it describes an illusion of connection between two people that is based on an idea of the love or the connection that you share rather than the truth. It is essentially a, a partial delusion. It can be based on someone's potential, a potential that they might not be ready or are incapable of fulfilling. But you hold on to the possibility because of what it could mean for
而这正是我今天真正想谈的。这就是我们在谈到约会时最常谈到的幻想粘合。幻想粘合的情况可能会发生在我们任何人身上，因为它基本上就像是依赖于一个非常人类的特征，那就是我们的想象力。它的作用是描述了两个人之间基于你分享的爱或联系的想法，而不是基于真相的连接幻觉。它本质上是一种局部的妄想。它可能基于某人的潜力，一种他们可能还没准备好或没有能力兑现的潜力。但你抓紧这种可能性，是因为这意味着如果你改变了，它可能会为你
you if they were to change. If they could be the fantasy. Essentially, it's having one version of this person in your mind and this other version of them that is real, not aligning. But we're unable to see that gap, that conflict between the fantasy and the reality. We all want to feel close to someone. We want intimacy. We want security. We want love. We want a relationship. And sometimes that can cause us to ignore a lack of genuine interest or compatibility or signs that this person is actually not right for us. They actually don't give us what we need. But by indulging in the fantasy of who this is that we have created for ourselves, the relationship can still be sustained and provide us things that we want in other areas. Another reason this might develop is when we place unrealistic expectations on
带来什么。如果他们能成为那个幻想。本质上，就是你脑海中的这个人的版本和他们真实的另一个版本并不一致。但我们无法看到这种差距，无法看到幻想与现实之间的冲突。我们都想和某人感到亲密。我们想要亲密感。我们想要安全感。我们想要爱。我们想要一段关系。有时这会让我们忽视缺乏真正的兴趣、契合度，或者忽视这个人实际上并不适合我们的迹象。他们实际上并没有给我们我们需要的东西。但是，通过沉溺于我们为自己创造的关于这个人的幻想，这段关系仍然可以维持，并在其他领域提供我们想要的东西。这种发展的另一个原因可能是我们将不切实际的期望寄托在
someone and we imagine that they can somehow solve all our problems. They are the one who can make us feel loved and chosen and seen and complete. And what this tends to do is cause us to accelerate our emotional bond. I think that love, what I've learned about love, is that it should feel really natural and easy and like a gradual progression and increasing closeness. The relationships where you like meet someone and you're instantly like, that is my soulmate, I need to tell them everything about me. I've often found that, you know, it's the saying, right? Like the candle that burns the brightest, like, goes out the fastest. Maybe that's this. It could be something else. But the idea is the same, right? That intensity is not sustainable. And so when we find ourselves
某人身上，我们想象他们能以某种方式解决我们所有的问题。他们是能让我们感到被爱、被选择、被看见和完整的那个人。这往往会导致我们加速我们的情感纽带。我认为爱，我关于爱的学到的是，它应该感觉非常自然、轻松，就像是一个逐渐推进和亲密感不断增加的过程。那些你遇到某人然后立即觉得“那是我的灵魂伴侣，我需要把我的一切都告诉他”的关系，我经常发现，正如那句俗话所说，对吧？就像燃烧得最亮的蜡烛，熄灭得最快。也许这就是这个。它可能是别的什么。但这个想法是一样的，对吧？那种强烈程度是不可持续的。所以当我们发现自己
creating a fantasy bond, we are, that intensity is really defining of those situations. And we often force a lot of artificial intimacy with them. So we might be like, I know I've only known you for a week, but let's go on a trip together. Like, do you want to, do you want to come on a trip? Do you want to, like, go on an overseas, like holiday, do you want to go on a weekend away? Or we'll be like, oh, by the way, like, my mom's in town. Why don't you just meet her? Why don't you just move in? You know, we've only don't know each other for like three weeks. Let's just move in together. And it's because that intensity, that artificial intimacy, allows us to overlook some of the things below the surface that doesn't match the vision,
创造了一个幻想粘合时，那种强烈程度确实在定义着这些情况。我们经常与他们强行制造大量的人工亲密感。所以我们可能会说：“我知道我只认识你一周，但我们一起去旅行吧。你想不想来？你想不想去海外度假，你想不想去度个周末？”或者我们会说：“哦，顺便说一句，我妈妈在镇上。你为什么不直接见见她？你为什么不直接搬进来？你知道，我们才认识三个星期。我们直接同居吧。”这是因为那种强烈程度、那种人工亲密感，让我们能够忽视表面之下的某些与愿景不符的事情，
doesn't match the idea of this person, because we are so blindsided by all of the excitement and how fast everything is moving. At the beginning of a relationship, we put on those rose-coloured lenses to ensure that the red flags look a lot more golden to us, or we ignore parts of this person that don't align with what we want. It also is seen in long-term relationship as well. People who have developed this type of bond often deceive themselves by imagining that they still love this person long after the feelings of affection and friendship and compassion and intimacy have faded because they want to be in love with them. So they continue to elevate the fantasy of what this person could be or it currently is. And what this causes us to do is to find comfort
与这个人的想法不匹配，因为我们被所有的兴奋和事情进展的速度冲昏了头脑。在一段关系的初期，我们戴上玫瑰色的眼镜，以确保红旗在我们看来更像是金色的，或者我们忽略了这个人的不符合我们想要的部分。它在长期关系中也可以看到。发展出这种类型纽带的人常常自我欺骗，想象在爱意、友情、同情和亲密感消逝很久之后，他们仍然深爱着这个人，因为他们渴望爱着他们。所以他们继续拔高这个人的潜能或现状的幻想。这导致我们去
and security in a dream in our imagination and therefore neglect or unfortunately turn away from possibilities that we could actually find genuine satisfaction with someone else. So, I've kind of spoken about a few reasons why this occurs, obviously. The pattern for this kind of dynamic begins in childhood for some of us, where we learn to do this with our parents. But additionally, there's also a lot of adult triggers or cues that create and replicate this kind of dynamic. Firstly, if you have been through a long period of, like, people who have just treated
在想象中的梦想里寻找舒适和安全，因此忽视了或者不幸地背离了我们其实可以从别人那里找到真正满足的可能性。所以，我显然已经谈到了一些发生这种情况的原因。这种动态的模式对我们中的一些人来说始于童年，我们在那里学会了对父母这样做。此外，还有许多成年人的触发因素或线索创造并复制了这种动态。首先，如果你经历了很长一段时间的，就像那些对待
you poorly, if you've just, you know, the last couple of years, everyone has, just kind of broken your heart or pulled away or hasn't want to commit, you are probably emotionally exhausted at this stage. Like, you are probably very tired. And you can't take another failure. You really can't. Your heart can't take it. So subconsciously, the next person who comes along, you create a fantasy bond because it's easier to overlook the things that would previously have caused a relationship to fail and therefore you avoid another disappointment. A lot of lot of us, myself included, I'm going to include myself in this box, have a very innate fear of being alone. It's only natural, I think it's one of our basic human needs, is belonging is
你很差的人，如果你刚刚，你知道，过去几年里，每个人都刚刚，只是伤了你的心，或者退缩了，或者不想承若，你在这个阶段可能已经情绪精疲力竭了。就像，你可能真的很累。而且你承受不起另一次失败。你真的承受不起。你的心承受不起。所以在潜意识里，当下一个出现的人到来时，你会创造一个幻想粘合，因为忽视那些以前会导致关系失败的事情会更容易，因此你可以避免又一次失望。我们很多人，包括我自己，我也把自己归入这一类，对孤独有着一种与生俱来的恐惧。这是很自然的，我认为这是我们最基本的人类需求之一，归属感就是
connection. So we'll do almost anything to obtain it, especially in a romantic form. And the fantasy that we create allows us to simultaneously avoid being alone, whilst also avoid seeing this person we're with for who they are. And if we were to see the real version of them, that isn't hidden behind our imaginative, you know, dream and vision, we probably wouldn't be with them. And we probably would ask for a lot more from the person we're with. It might also be that this person is like so close to being the right one, so almost perfect that we're like, you know what, this is good enough. If you don't feel like you deserve the best, if you don't feel like you deserve the kind of love that everyone talks about that is perfect and fulfilling and made for you, you will settle.
连接。所以我们会为了得到它而几乎做任何事，特别是在浪漫的形式中。我们创造的幻想使我们能够同时避免孤独，同时又避免把我们身边的这个人看作他们本来面目。如果我们看到他们真实的、没有隐藏在我们充满想象力的梦想和愿景背后的版本，我们可能不会和他们在一起。我们可能会对我们身边的人要求更多。也可能是这个人如此接近正确的那个人，几乎完美到我们觉得：“你知道的，这就够了。如果你觉得自己不配得到最好的，如果你觉得自己不配得到那种每个人都在谈论的完美、充实且为你而设的爱，你就会将就。”
And there will be a sense of a part of you that will not want to settle. But the fantasy fills that gap because it allows you to once again see everything through those rose-tinted glasses. So this creates the fantasy bonding cycle. You feel a deep, almost irrational longing for this person. You begin to find that all of your thoughts find their way back to them. You place them on a pedestal. And you create, once again, the image of them that is vastly different from who they actually are. And it's this image that makes you fall in love more, makes you fall in deeper because you are the ones sustaining it.
而且你会有一种感觉，你内心深处的一部分并不想将就。但幻想填补了这一空白，因为它让你再次透过玫瑰色的眼镜看待一切。这就形成了幻想依恋循环。你会对这个人产生一种深沉的、几乎是不理智的渴望。你会发现你所有的思念最终都会回到他们身上。你把他们高高供奉起来。你再次为他们塑造了一个与他们真实面目大相径庭的形象。正是这个形象让你越陷越深，因为这一切都是由你在苦苦维系。
So the connection that you have with them, it feels real. But it also simultaneously is allowing you to overlook a lot of red flags. It's allowing you to minimize some of the disappointment, some of the letdowns. It may also be that you continue a relationship based on the good times you had in the past. You're only there because you think you can get back to that when there was, you know, there might not be an indication that that is true. You know, the fantasy that you initially created may begin to disintegrate and deteriorate, but actually that causes you to invest more in the illusion because you have a lot to lose now.
所以你与他们之间的这种联系，感觉是真实的。但与此同时，它也让你忽视了许多危险信号。它让你选择性地忽视了一些失望和挫折。也可能是因为你沉溺于过去的美好时光，才让这段关系得以维持。你留下来只是因为你觉得还能回到过去那种状态，而事实上，种种迹象可能根本并非如此。你知道，你最初创造的幻想可能会开始瓦解和破碎，但实际上，这反而会促使你对这个幻象投入更多，因为你现在输不起。
So this causes us to once again turn up the intensity, create more closeness again and again. You keep pushing it. But also ignore your gut instinct when it comes to the real level. relationship. I talk about gut instinct. I actually think quite a bit on this podcast now that I'm thinking about it because I really believe in it. I have a deep belief that this type of like physical, visceral intuition is often correct. And in fact, we've actually seen in a lot of studies recently confirming that intuition is a very real psychological process in which subconsciously, unconsciously, our brains are making assessments that we don't particularly know about on a conscious level
因此，这导致我们再次调高强烈程度，一次又一次地创造更多的亲密感。你不断地在推进。但同时，当面对真实的恋情时，你也忽视了自己的直觉。说到直觉，我现在回想起来，在这个播客里我其实挺常谈到这个话题的，因为我是真的深信不疑。我深信这种身体本能的直觉往往是正确的。事实上，我们最近在许多研究中也看到，这些研究证实了直觉是一个非常真实的心理过程，在这个过程中，我们的潜意识和无意识在进行着我们意识层面并未察觉的评估，
in order to get us to the right decision. So it is using past experiences, it is using environmental and internal cues to kind of guide us in the right direction, even if that process, that end thought, that conclusion isn't explicit. It's intuitive, it feels implicit. But when there is a much stronger urge to go a different way, when like our like front brain, our like active brain is being like, no, I want love. I want a relationship. I'm going to just go with this person. We can really ignore the valuable insight that is brought by this kind of gut feeling. And so when we're caught in a fantasy bond, we end up
从而引导我们做出正确的决定。因此，它会利用过去的经验、环境和内在的线索来指引我们朝着正确的方向前进，即使这个过程、最终的想法或结论并不是那么明确。它是直观的，感觉上是内隐的。但是，当出现更强烈的冲动去选择另一条路时，当我们的大脑前额叶、活跃的大脑在说“不，我想要爱，我想要一段感情，我就要和这个人在一起”时，我们真的会忽视这种直觉所带来的宝贵洞察。所以，当我们陷入幻想依恋时，最终会
surrendering a lot of things. We end up, you know, surrendering a lot of our needs, surrendering a lot of our identity, surrendering a lot of our boundaries to sustain the relationship. And I have seen a lot consequences of this in my own life. I would say one of the biggest, like, consequences of a fantasy bond are these really drawn out situationships that we find ourselves in, situationships that are defined by a lot of longing, a lot of wishful thinking, and inevitably a broken heart. And this primarily occurs because we ignore this person's lack of commitment. We excuse it by thinking that They just need more time or that if we offer more of ourselves up, they will change their mind. We just need to be better.
牺牲很多东西。为了维持这段关系，我们最终会牺牲许多自己的需求，牺牲许多自我认同，牺牲许多个人底线。我在自己的生活中也看到过很多这样的后果。我想说，幻想依恋最严重的后果之一，就是我们发现自己深陷于那些被无限拉长的暧昧关系中。这种关系充满了渴望、一厢情愿的美好愿望，以及不可避免的心碎。这种情况的发生，主要是因为我们忽视了对方缺乏承诺的态度。我们为之开脱，认为他们只是需要更多时间，或者只要我们付出更多，他们就会改变心意。我们只是需要变得更好。
We need to do something that is going to convince them. That is not true. This person is not who you want them to be. Your perception of the potential future with this person is based on false premises. It's based on you misconstruing reality, once again, on the illusion of someone. Falling in love with someone's potential is both an unconscious but also a dangerous, but also a dangerous. game, even if we don't mean it to be. A couple years back, actually, I met this guy, and it was straight out of a long-term relationship. And I became like, I was so, I think, firstly, emotionally
我们需要做出一些能够说服他们的举动。事实并非如此。这个人并不是你所希望的那样。你对与这个人未来可能性的看法，是建立在错误的前提之上的。它建立在你再次曲解现实的基础之上，建立在对某人的幻象之上。爱上一个人的潜力，既是一个无意识的游戏，也是一个危险的游戏，哪怕我们的本意并非如此。其实就在几年前，我遇到了一个男生，当时我刚结束一段长期恋爱。我变得……我想，首先我情绪上非常
vulnerable that I became immediately attached to him because of the idea of what he could bring me, which was the love that I really missed. And with that, I didn't want to accept the fact that, like, maybe I actually just needed a rebound. I had to accept the fact that this was the one. And what ensued was a really great deal of toxic hope. I ignored how fickle he was. I ignored how often I was a second choice for him. I ignored how he put me down, how every time I tried to talk about the future, he would be incredibly dismissive because it was important for me to ignore that to continue the relationship. Because I think if I had acknowledged it, there was no way that I would stay. There was no way I was going to be there. And so I just kept the fantasy up. I just kept ignoring it. And that was also just not a
脆弱，所以因为对“他能带给我什么（也就是我极其渴望的爱）”这种概念的向往，我立刻对他产生了依恋。带着这种心态，我不愿意接受这样一个事实：也许我当时需要的只是一个疗伤止损的过渡恋情。我必须让自己相信这就是真命天子。随之而来的是大量有毒的希望。我忽视了他的反复无常。我忽视了自己频繁沦为他的第二选择。我忽视了他是如何贬低我的，忽视了每次我试图谈论未来时他那种极其敷衍冷漠的态度，因为对于维持这段关系来说，忽视这些对我而言至关重要。因为我觉得如果我承认了这些，我就绝不可能再留下来。我绝不可能继续待在那里。所以我只能苦苦维持这个幻想。我只能不断地视而不见。而且那也绝不是一桩
to me, and I think if I had initially known that sooner and applied the necessary boundaries, it wouldn't have lasted for so long. But the thing is, is that the fantasy doesn't make itself known until afterwards. And so it's easier to say it now, in hindsight, but at the time, obviously, like, I can only believe what my mind tells me, and my mind is also creating this, like, imaginative person and this, like, vision of this person. And so that's what I'm going to believe. the other relational consequence of ignoring who someone truly is for the fantasy is that inevitably as the relationship progresses you will end up trying to change them so that they match the idea of what you initially wanted in them as a partner because you haven't truly bonded with
对我的感情，我想如果我当初能早点意识到这一点，并设立必要的边界，这段关系就不会持续这么久了。但问题是，幻想往往是在事后才会显现出来。所以现在事后诸葛亮说起来很容易，但在当时，很明显，我只能相信我的大脑告诉我的东西，而我的大脑也在创造这个虚构的人和对这个人的美好愿景。所以这就是我所坚信的。因为幻想而忽视一个人的真实面目，所带来的另一个人际关系方面的后果是，随着关系的进展，你不可避免地会试图改变他们，让他们符合你最初作为伴侣所期望的形象，因为你并未真正与
who they are in reality because you've bonded with the fantasy eventually that imagined version and that real version are not going to align they're going to come into conflict and instead of being able to accept that maybe you were just wrong about them, you're going to look for ways to solve the problem. Honestly, I'm going to say this a little bit of a caveat. I don't think you need to love everything about your partner at all times. Like, that's not to say that if you find things that like maybe annoy you a little bit or little habits that you would like to change that potentially you've actually fantasy bonded. But what I'm really speaking about here is significant things that you have obviously at some point overlooked in favor of this person's potential. And
他们的现实本质建立连接，而是与幻想建立了连接，最终，那个想象中的版本和真实的版本必然无法契合，两者会产生冲突。而你不会去接受“或许一开始就是你看走眼了”这个事实，而是会去寻找解决问题的方法。说实话，我要在这里做一个小小的补充说明。我并不是说你必须时刻喜欢伴侣身上的所有事情。我的意思是，如果你发现有些事情稍微有点让你恼火，或者有一些你希望改变的小习惯，这并不意味着你真的患上了幻想依恋。但我这里真正要说的是那些重大的事情，它们是你为了这个人的潜力和未来，在某个时刻明显选择忽视的。而且
they're big things. I'm talking religious differences. I'm talking extreme lifestyle differences. These are things that you can only ignore for so long. The fantasy can only stay intact for so long before you're going to want something to change. And it leads to a lot of conflict because this person doesn't want to change. They never promised they would. They feel a little bit blindsided. And they also feel incapable. It's going to put a strain on the relationship. And most of the time it will lead it to fall apart because it's almost like you wake up and you realize that you are in love with someone who does not exist. You are in love with someone that you created in your mind. And I think that the result of that is that we feel a lot of regret because we wasted our time. We feel like we've
这些都是大事。我说的是宗教信仰的差异。我说的极端的生活方式差异。这些都是你不可能无限期忽视下去的事情。幻想只能维持那么久，直到你开始渴望某些改变。这会导致大量的冲突，因为这个人并不想改变。他们从未承诺过改变。他们会觉得有些措手不及。他们也会觉得自己无能为力。这会给关系带来压力。大多数时候，这会导致关系破裂，因为这就好像你一觉醒来，突然意识到自己爱上了一个根本不存在的人。你爱上的是一个你在脑海中凭空捏造的人。我认为这样做的结果是，我们会感到无比后悔，因为我们浪费了时间。我们觉得自己
misled ourselves. We feel angry. We feel hurt. We feel heartbroken. Because like how could we have done this? You know, who was this person that we loved? Where did we get this from? But I really want to remind you that it's not a conscious choice. It comes from so many things. You also probably have a very big heart. You have an optimistic personality. You want to see the best in people. You want to believe that they can be the best versions of themselves, that they can change, that they can be their potential. That is why you find yourselves in these relationships with people where like you're just constantly thinking it's going to get better. This fantasy that you have of them is reality. because to not believe that would really hurt.
误导了自己。我们感到愤怒。我们感到受伤。我们感到心碎。因为我们怎么会做出这种事？我们深爱的那个人究竟是谁？我们到底是从哪儿弄来这么个人？但我真的很想提醒大家，这不是一个有意识的选择。它是诸多因素共同作用的结果。你可能也拥有一颗非常善良的心。你有着乐观的个性。你总是希望看到别人最好的一面。你愿意相信他们能成为最好的自己，相信他们能够改变，相信他们能发挥出自身的潜力。这就是为什么你会陷入这些关系中，和这样的人在一起，不断地幻想着情况会变好。你对他们的这种幻想就是现实，因为不去相信这一点会让人痛不欲生。
So what I actually want to talk about next is how we can prevent the fantasy bond before it even begins, especially for people who are hopeless romantics, people who are maybe just attracted to the idea of anyone who's offering them love, who sees the best in everyone. Even when they let us down, I really want to talk about that next. So all of that and more after this short break. 2%.
所以我接下来真正想谈的是，我们如何在幻想依恋萌芽之前就将其扼杀在摇篮里，特别是对于那些无可救药的浪漫主义者来说，对那些可能仅仅被任何给予他们爱的人所吸引、总能看到每个人最好一面的人来说。即使当这些人让我们失望时，我真的很想在接下来探讨这个话题。所有这些以及更多内容，就在这段简短的广告之后。2%。
That is the number of people who take the stairs, when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts,
这就是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇特现代世界中精神坚韧、体能锻炼以及培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家展开对话，
and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong, Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
等等，以此看穿那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油本质上会导致发炎。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就能在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And Rule 2, never mess with her friends either. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
收听《2%》。这就是I-Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的“T-W-O-Persent”。每个男人都应该遵循两条黄金法则。规则一，千万不要去惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的下场。规则二，也千万别去惹她的朋友们。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在《闺蜜》的新一季中……天哪，这就是同一个人。一群女性发现她们竟然都和同一个惯犯骗子约会过。
I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care, so they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no. I vowed I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
我感觉自己就像被卡车撞了。心想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在意，于是她们决定自己动手。我心想，哦，见鬼去吧。我发誓我绝对不会成为他的最后一个目标。他会得到应有的下场。收听《闺蜜》。相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush
在Iheart radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底跟
got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jette）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析其来龙去脉，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段时期的。包括最近一期节目中，马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都能聊聊当年的快克，只是想让大家知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，马克，说到这儿，这已经是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆上了台面。谢谢你帮我把话说完。我不认为还有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？对，对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，在我们追求某事的过程中，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. So how exactly do we prevent a fantasy bond from forming? I think it's all well and good to talk about the origins and the wise and the Watts and all of those things. But actually this doesn't help us unless we know what to do about it. So I'm going to give you some of my best tips as a former prolific fantasy,
我希望你能真正做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，由我基尔·盖恩斯带你一起，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的IHeart Radio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。那么，我们究竟该如何防止幻想依恋的形成呢？我觉得探讨它的起源、原因、方式以及所有这些理论都挺好。但实际上，如果我们不知道该怎么做，这些理论对我们毫无帮助。所以，我将作为曾经的资深幻想倾向、
idealized kind of person, kind of data. Firstly, in the beginning, when you're first starting to see someone, spread out your dates with them in order to not get attached too quickly. When we meet someone that we like, of course you want to see them. all the time. Of course you want the reassurance that they want to see you, that they want to continue going on dates with you. Let it naturally, like let it naturally form though, let it take like a natural progression instead of trying to create that intensity that we spoke about. I think physical proximity and frequencies is it's naturally going to cause you to feel
理想主义者，向大家提供我的一些最佳建议，算是某种经验之谈吧。首先，在刚开始接触的阶段，当你刚开始和某人约会时，把约会的时间间隔拉长一些，以免过快产生依恋。当我们遇到喜欢的人时，你当然会想一直见到他们。你当然希望得到对方也想见你、想继续和你约会的保证。不过，还是让它自然发展吧，让它顺其自然地推进，而不是试图去制造我们之前谈到过的那种强烈的情感。我认为身体的亲密接触和高频率的见面，自然会让你在真正了解
closer to someone before you've actually gotten an idea of who they really are and what they can offer you. So take time between your dates with someone to actually reflect, to actually make sure you're looking after yourself, you are your own person, you're not getting caught up in like this whirlwind. And you don't get completely engulfed by this new person either. It's really interesting because I think that like the consequences of fantasy bonding are like intense emotional availability compared to emotional unavailability. And we don't want. either of those things, right? We want to balance between the two. It's very easy to go the other direction and put on this like image of being very cold and very heartless and very like, I don't
对方是谁以及他们能为你提供什么之前，就先对对方产生亲近感。所以在和某人的约会之间留出时间来真正反思，真正确保你在照顾好自己，你是一个独立的个体，你没有被卷入这场旋风般的感情中。而且你也没有完全被这个新的人所吞噬。这真的很有趣，因为我认为幻想依恋的后果就是，相较于情感疏离，它表现为一种过度强烈的感情可获得性。而这两种极端我们都不希望要，对吧？我们希望在两者之间找到平衡。走向另一个极端也很容易，那就是摆出一副非常冷酷、毫无心肝、一副“我不在乎”的姿态，
know, detached. That's also not the way to find love. So I think if you want a number, I would say when you first start dating someone, a week between dates is really good. And then after like the third date, you can kind of increase after like the 10th date you should increase as well. I also think do not look for a label too soon. You actually need time to test things. You need time to actually know this person and know who they are and know they want to know what they can give you rather than what you think they can give you, if that makes sense. Part of that is having a list of non-negotiables.
你知道的，若即若离。那也不是找到真爱的方法。所以我想如果你想要一个具体的时间间隔，我会说当你刚开始和某人约会时，约会之间隔一周真的很好。然后在大约第三次约会后，你可以稍微增加间隔，在大约第10次约会后，你也应该增加间隔。我还认为不要太快寻找名分。你实际上需要时间去检验事情。你需要时间去真正了解这个人，知道他们是谁，知道他们想知道他们能给你什么，而不是你认为他们能给你什么，如果这说得通的话。其中的一部分就是列出一份不可妥协的条件清单。
If you know that you are particularly susceptible to this kind of bond, which I'm assuming you know because you're listening to this episode, make sure that your rational voice is speaking louder than your romantic voice, than your like fantasy voice, if that makes sense. When you meet someone you really like, it's so easy to get super carried away in them, intoxicated by them, that we actually forget what we're really looking for, and we forget what we really want and what we really deserve. That is where your non-negotiables come into play.
如果你知道自己特别容易受到这种羁绊的影响，我猜你知道是因为你在听这一集，确保你的理性声音比你的浪漫声音、比你的幻想声音更大，如果这说得通的话。当你遇到一个你真正喜欢的人时，很容易完全沉浸在他们之中，被他们陶醉，以至于我们实际上忘记了我们真正在寻找什么，我们忘记了我们真正想要什么以及我们真正应得的是什么。这就是你的不可妥协条件发挥作用的地方。
I've talked about this on the show before. I think that you should have a list. And I know that sounds like super rule-based and super intense. But honestly, it's going to save you a lot of pain in the long run if you say, okay, here are the five things that I absolutely need in a partner. I absolutely need them to be consistent. I absolutely need them to be kind. I absolutely need them to live close to me.
我以前在节目中谈过这个。我认为你应该有一张清单。我知道这听起来超级死板，超级强烈。但老实说，如果你说，好吧，这里是我对伴侣绝对需要的五件事，从长远来看，它会为你省去很多痛苦。我绝对需要他们始终如一。我绝对需要他们善良。我绝对需要他们住得离我很近。
I absolutely need them to like do nice things with me, plan dates. I absolutely need them to whatever. Have that list. And if they're not meeting those kinds of priorities for you, that is your sign to let them go. That is your, that is you going back to the version of you that was rational before you met this person, before you may have bonded with them through the fantasy, telling you what to do. You are going to have to listen to your own self. You're going to have to listen to the opinion that probably matters the most, which is your own.
我绝对需要他们喜欢和我一起做美好的事情，策划约会。我绝对需要他们做别的什么。列出那份清单。如果他们没有达到你这些优先事项，那就是你放手他们的信号。那是你，那是你回到在你遇到这个人之前、在你可能通过幻想与他们建立羁绊之前那个理性的自己，告诉你该做什么。你将不得不听从你自己的心声。你将不得不听从可能最重要那个人的意见，那就是你自己的意见。
the other thing here is remember potential is not the same as actuality and you really need to make sure that you are honest with yourself about whether your attraction is based on who you want them to be or who they are in the moment so when you like start telling your friends about them or when you start talking to yourself about them when they're not around being like wow they are really so so kind and they're really like super this and super that do you have examples of that Is that true? I want you to remember an example of it. I don't want you to start applying additional,
这里另一件事是记住潜力不等同于现实，你真的需要确保你对自己诚实，你的吸引力是基于你希望他们成为的人，还是基于他们当下的样子。所以当你开始向朋友们讲述他们时，或者当他们不在身边时你开始对自己讲述他们时，心想“哇，他们真的是太善良了，他们真的是超级这样和超级那样”，你有这样的例子吗？这是真的吗？我希望你能记住一个例子。我不想你开始附加额外...
you know, very generous character traits to this person when they're not actually there. On the flip side of this, the other side of the coin is, are there any negative emotions that you are suppressing that you know don't sit right right now, that you might be concealing by trying to speak more positively of this person? You once again need to trust your,
你知道的，对这个人非常慷慨的性格特征，而他们实际上并不在那里。另一方面，硬币的另一面是，你是否有任何你正在压抑的负面情绪，你知道现在感觉不对劲，你可能试图通过对这个人做出更积极的评价来掩盖这些情绪？你再次需要相信你的...
gut, it is going to tell you things that you need to hear and you need to listen to it. Is there something about this person that just doesn't feel quite right that you were ignoring just because you want a relationship? Are there things you're not telling your friends? That's a big one. It's sometimes I think hard to be honest with ourselves and we need that external accountability and our friends are great for that. If there is something that this person has done,
直觉，它会告诉你你需要听到的事情，你需要倾听它。这个人身上是不是有些东西感觉不太对劲，而你只是因为想要一段恋爱关系而选择忽视？有没有什么事情你没有告诉你的朋友？这是一个大问题。有时我认为很难对自己诚实，我们需要这种外部的责任感，我们的朋友在这方面很棒。如果这个人做过什么事...
if there's something they're not offering you, that you're like, this actually really bothers me and you wouldn't tell your friends about it because you know they would have an opinion that might go against what you want from the situation, what your fantasy wants, that is a pretty big red flag
如果有什么事情是他们没有给予你的，而你会觉得“这其实真的很困扰我”，并且你不会把这件事告诉你的朋友，因为你知道他们会有可能会违背你从这种情况中想要的、违背你的幻想想要的意见，那是一个相当大的危险信号...
that you should not be ignoring. One of the other ones is avoiding actually bringing up things that are bothering you because you want this relationship to work. And I guess that conflict aversion is so common, it's so common. It really is just people pleasing in a new form, but also sometimes we can implicitly avoid bringing up the things that we might need because it is a way of protecting us from acknowledging the fantasy that is occurring.
你不应该忽视它。另一个表现是，因为你想要这段关系能够维持下去，所以避免真正提出困扰你的事情。我猜这种逃避冲突非常普遍，太普遍了。它真的只是换了一种新形式的取悦他人，但有时我们也会含蓄地避免提出我们可能需要的东西，因为这是保护我们免于承认正在发生的幻想的一种方式。
Something is upsetting you, but if you were to acknowledge it, it would mean that it would counter, like, it would contradict the vision. It would contradict who this person is. So I think in those moments when something like, whether it's a lack of commitment, whether it's a lack of consistency, they're not replying to your text messages, they never want to do things with you like before 7pm, like they don't want to meet your friends, they don't want to like show that they care about you. And you're just like almost waiting on them to do that.
有什么事情让你心烦意乱，但如果你承认它，就意味着它会反驳，就像，它会违背这种愿景。它会违背这个人的真实身份。所以我认为在那些时刻，当发生诸如缺乏承诺、缺乏一致性之类的事情时，他们不回复你的短信，他们从不想在晚上7点之前和你一起做事，比如他们不想见你的朋友，他们不想表现出他们在乎你。而你几乎只是在等他们这样做。
That's no, no, no. We're not waiting anymore. If that is, if your non-negotiable say you want someone who is consistent, you want someone who puts an effort and they're not doing that, it doesn't matter if you're scared of conflict. You need to do this for yourself and you need to recognize that there is an unconscious part of you, a very rudimentary and primal part of you that is actually not letting you see this clearly. When we get to this point, I think you do need to end things and treat it like a breakup,
这不行，不行，不行。我们再也不会等了。如果那是，如果你的底线要求是一个始终如一的人，你想要一个付出努力的人而他们没有这样做，无论你是否害怕冲突都无所谓。你需要为自己这样做，你需要认识到你的内心有一个无意识的部分，一个非常初级和原始的部分，它实际上并没有让你看清这一点。当我们到达这一步时，我认为你确实需要结束这一切，并把它当作一次分手来对待，
no matter how long you've been together, even if labels or exclusivity was never spoken of, I think I really struggle when I see people have what are these very emotionally intense relationships and then deny themselves the grief that they deserve. This still touched you. This still was important to you. And relationships, however long they are, this was still a relationship. If it ends abruptly, it will create an emotional vortex, especially after the intensity of a fantasy bond.
无论你们在一起多久，即使从未谈过名分或排他性，我想当我看到人们拥有这种情绪非常强烈的情感关系，然后却否定他们应得的悲伤时，我真的很难过。这依然触动了你。这依然对你很重要。无论多长时间，这也是一段关系。如果它突然结束，它会产生一个情感旋涡，尤其是在经历了强烈的幻想羁绊之后。
the memories feel bigger when they have become inflated by expectation. So it's normal to feel a little bit mentally and emotionally unstable. Because you're kind of also at the same time as you're grieving the potential of this person, you're grieving the what-ifs. You're also floating back down to reality in the aftermath. So some tips at this stage is ignore the need for closure if you do end things. As humans, I think we love closure. we crave closure because we are really bad at dealing with uncertainty and we want answers.
当记忆被期望膨胀时，它们感觉更宏大了。所以感到精神和情绪有点不稳定是很正常的。因为你在为这个人的潜力悲伤的同时，你也在为“如果……”悲伤。你在余波中也回到了现实。所以在现阶段的一些小建议是：如果你确实结束了这一切，请忽略对结局的需求。作为人类，我想我们都喜欢圆满。我们渴望结局，因为我们很不擅长应对不确定性，我们想要答案。
It is this thing that they talk about a lot in psychology is, it also unlike the psychology around trauma as well and how we make memories, how we process memories, is that we like our stories to have a nice ending because that means that we can properly place those memories in their proper location, in their proper box. We like when chapters are closed. We like when they're a conclusions. And when that doesn't come, when the chapter isn't ending, as we thought it would, because we haven't been given the emotional and psychological closure we need, it can be super confusing. The thing about ending a relationship that is defined by a fantasy bond is that closure probably won't come for a while. That because there is nothing this person can say
这就是心理学中经常讨论的事情，它也不同于围绕创伤的心理学以及我们如何制造记忆、如何处理记忆，那就是我们喜欢我们的故事有一个美好的结局，因为这意味着我们可以把这些记忆适当地放在它们合适的位置、合适的盒子里。我们喜欢章节合上。我们喜欢有结论的时候。当这一切没有到来，当章节没有像我们想象的那样结束时，因为我们没有得到所需的情感和心理上的闭环，这可能会超级令人困惑。结束一段由幻想羁绊定义的关系的事情在于，这种闭环可能在一段时间内都不会到来。因为这个人没有什么话可以说...
that will make you feel okay, because they aren't the person that you believe they were. They are not, they are not that character anymore. And so you're looking for answers from someone who, quite frankly, doesn't exist. You thought he was this great guy, he wasn't this great guy, but you're still expecting him to act like it. You know, I think that it's really difficult in that situation because part of you will also be like, okay, I want to move on. I don't want to remember this person.
能让你感觉好一点，因为他们不是你所认为的那个人。他们不是，他们不再是那个角色了。所以你在向一个坦白说并不存在的人寻找答案。你以为他是个很棒的家伙，他并不是那个很棒的家伙，但你仍然期望他表现得像个很棒的家伙。你知道，我认为在这种情况下真的很难，因为你的一部分也会觉得，好吧，我想继续前行。我不想再记住这个人。
I don't want to keep sitting in the what-ifs, but you can hold those emotions without letting them rule you. You can feel sad. You can feel disappointed. You can feel that fear of loneliness, that desire for love without needing to go back to that person. I think you just need to learn from it in that moment. What were the signs that in hindsight, you probably couldn't see as clearly at the time? I also want to remind you that the fact that you have formed this bond with someone's potential,
我不想继续陷入“如果……”中，但你可以保持这些情绪，而不让它们统治你。你可以感到难过。你可以感到失望。你可以感受到对孤独的恐惧、对爱的渴望，而不需要回到那个人身边。我想你只需要在那一刻从中吸取教训。事后看来，那些你当时可能无法看清的迹象是什么？我还想提醒你，你与某个人的潜力建立了这种羁绊这一事实，
that you have this fantasy about them, is a really beautiful thing. it's because you have a very pure and good heart. You know, you do see the best in people. You are generous. Your mind has, like, gone through hoops, has turned so many twisty corners to make sure that this person looked good in your mind's eye, that they continued to have a good reputation in your imagination.
你对他们抱有这种幻想，这是一件非常美好的事情。那是因为你有一颗非常纯洁善良的心。你知道，你确实看到了人们最好的一面。你很慷慨。你的心智经历了种种周折，转了那么多弯弯绕绕，以确保这个人印在你的脑海里时看起来很好，他们在你的想象中继续拥有良好的声誉。
As a way of healing, I do honestly think you should listen to the breakup episode that we did last year for more tips on this. But the number one thing I would say is get back to a place of independence where you actually begin to reinforce how worthwhile and amazing you are. You don't need a fantasy of someone because you deserve the real thing. You know, you deserve more than what your imagination has concocted for you. Part of that is also just, I think part of why we end up in these situationships
作为一种疗愈的方式，老实说，我认为你应该去听听我们去年做的那期关于分手的节目，以获取更多这方面的建议。但我会给出的第一条建议是：回到独立的状态，重新去强化你是多么有价值、多么了不起。你不需要对某个人的幻想，因为你值得拥有真实的东西。你知道，你的价值超过了你的想象力为你虚构的东西。其中一部分也只是，我认为我们最终陷入这些无名分的暧昧关系...
and these relationships and these like weird dynamics is because we don't necessarily feel like super confident in who we are as a person. We maybe don't feel super fulfilled or entertained by our lives. So work on bringing back those hobbies. I saw this amazing video the other day of this woman who is spending the year doing the things that she used to do as a kid. When we're younger, we have all of these like amazing parts of us and we are like these super active and like incredible people and we have hobbies and whatnot and so many different talents. And we lose that as we get older. And we sometimes tend to replace those things, those activities, with relationships.
以及这些恋爱关系和这些奇怪的动态，部分原因是我们不一定对作为个体的自己感到超级自信。我们可能觉得生活没有给我们带来超级大的满足感或娱乐感。所以，努力把那些爱好找回来吧。前几天我看到一个神奇的视频，一个女人用一整年时间去做她小时候做过的事情。当我们年轻的时候，我们身上所有这些美妙的部分都被激活了，我们就像超级活跃、不可思议的人，我们有爱好等等，还有许多不同的才华。随着年龄的增长，我们失去了这些。有时我们倾向于用恋爱关系来替代那些东西、那些活动。
And we let them be our main source of entertainment. And we can really lose ourselves in that. So get back to your hobbies, get back to your friends, get back to yourself, and kind of tend to those secret gardens that you contain within you. I talk about this analogy a lot, but each of us has these little parts of us that really no one is ever fully going to understand. These little quarks, these little interests, these things that make you curious that are precious and just for you, make sure that you're tending to those. It is totally okay if you got wrapped up in the idea of someone. We've all been there. I've been there
我们让他们成为我们娱乐的主要来源，我们真的会在其中迷失自我。所以回到你的爱好中去，回到你的朋友身边，回到你自己身边，去照料你内心中包含的那些秘密花园。我经常谈到这个比喻，但我们每个人都有这样一小部分，真的没有人能完全理解。这些小怪癖，这些小兴趣，这些让你充满好奇、珍贵且专属于你的东西，确保你去照料它们。如果你沉浸在对某个人 idealized（理想化）的想法中，那是完全没问题的。我们都经历过。我也经历过...
so many times we want to see people be their best. We want them, we want to believe that they could be what we want and we want love. We want a relationship. So when we get to a point of maybe exhaustion with dating and exhaustion with a lot of dead ends, our mind is going to find a solution to that problem, and it's going to use all the tools it has, including our imagination. So I don't want you to feel any shame. And I also really hope that this episode has taught you something
很多很多次，我们希望看到人们展现最好的一面。我们希望他们，我们想要相信他们可以成为我们想要的样子，我们想要爱。我们想要一段关系。因此，当我们对约会感到筋疲力尽、对许多死胡同感到筋疲力尽时，我们的脑海会找到解决该问题的方法，并且它会使用拥有的所有工具，包括我们的想象力。所以我不想让你感到任何羞耻。我也真诚地希望这一集能教给你一些东西，
about this dynamic, that you've learned something, that you have something to apply to your own life, or at least that you're looking out for these kinds of bonds and know why they form. I think it really is important to talk about because a lot of people end up in relationships with these people, with this kind of person that they've bonded with for years. And they don't realize what's happened until like ages down the line.
关于这种动态，你学到了东西，你有可以应用到自己生活中的东西，或者至少你在留心这类羁绊，并且知道它们为什么会形成。我认为谈论这个真的很重要，因为很多人最终会和这种人、和这种他们与之建立了羁绊多年的人建立恋爱关系。直到很久以后，他们才意识到发生了什么。
And suddenly it's this huge shock. But if you catch it early, if you know that's how you form attachments with people, you can kind of prevent that from happening. So thank you so much for listening to this episode. If you enjoyed this episode, remember to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, with a friend if you think they might need to hear what we talked about today. And as always, if you have an episode suggestion, if you have something to say, if you have an experience with
突然间这是一个巨大的打击。但如果你早点发现它，如果你知道这就是你与人建立依恋的方式，你就可以在某种程度上防止这种情况发生。非常感谢你收听本期节目。如果你喜欢这期节目，记得在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星评价，如果你认为某个朋友可能需要听听我们今天讨论的内容，请把节目分享给他们。一如既往，如果你有节目建议，如果你有话要说，如果你有关于...
fantasy bonding, please reach out to me on Instagram at that psychology podcast. I would love to hear from you. I would love to hear about your experience. We can create a little support group or something like that. But sending you love, sending you strength. And we will be back next week with another episode. On the Look Back at a podcast. for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English.
幻想羁绊的经历，请在Instagram上通过 @thatpsychology podcast 联系我。我很想听到你的声音。我很想听听你的经历。我们可以建立一个小互助小组之类的东西。向你发送爱，发送力量。我们下周会带着另一集回归。在“Look Back at it”播客中。对我来说，84对我来说很大。我是 Sam Jay。我是 Alex English。
Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year.
每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何在其中生存下来的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如 Mark Lamont Hill 谈论 80 年代。84年是疯狂的一年。这是一个疯狂的年头。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences,
我认为没有比这更重要的一年了，对于黑人而言。在 iHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back At It。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？欢迎收听 Learn the Hard Way，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着盔甲生活？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Learn the Hard Way。在 2023 年，单身汉明星 Clayton Eckerd 被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次并进行推销，对吗？我篡改测试了一次。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋者。Michael Marantini。我的天哪，太震惊了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
我是 Stephanie Young。这是 Love Trapped。Laura，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，Laura Owens 终于面临了后果。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。2%。这是当有自动扶梯可用时，选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是 Michael Easter。
I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%? That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我的播客 2% 中。我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你会走出来。在另一边，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。在 iHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听 2%？那是数字 2%。这是一档 iHeart 播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。